CALVIN KIZANA: I
guess our story is
one I hope can inspire
other developers,
that reaching a global
audience is possible.
PicMix started out purely as a
photo-video editing and sharing
app, but today has evolved into
an internet-based community,
content discovery, and
social commerce platform.
My name is Calvin Kizana, CEO
and co-founder of Inovidea,
the developers of PicMix.
Today we have more than 27
million users worldwide, mainly
on Android devices.
65% of our users
is international.
We realized that to appeal
to a global audience,
we needed to create a
very high-quality app.
We decided to take advantage of
Google Play's developer tools.
SANDY COLONDAM:
I'm Sandy Colondam,
co-founder at Inovidea,
developers of PicMix.
We needed an intuitive
interface, and the only way
to do that is to follow
the same set of guidelines
that Android was built on.
We just made a clear design.
Before we implemented Google
material design guidelines,
the time our users spent in
the app was, like, two minutes.
It jumped to eight minutes now,
and we see a massive increase
in likes and comments.
PicMix's main feature is
photo and video editing,
so it's very crucial
that our users can easily
access to create new
photo and video content.
And then we saw a huge increase
in the numbers of photos being
created by first-time
users, and this
was when we really began to
see traction with our user base
on a global scale.
Another thing we
did was to improve
the quality of our store
listing on Google Play.
This allowed us to test multiple
versions of our store listing
and to see which one
our users liked best.
Store listing experiment
really helped us
to avoid making big mistakes.
We decided to change
the PicMix icon to pink,
to coincide with
Valentine's Day.
But the download rate
actually decreased by 8%.
So this was a very big
learning point to us,
and the obvious choice was to
go back to the blue-colored one.
CALVIN KIZANA: When I
first started this company
four years ago, I
never imagined it
can be so successful
just like today,
especially on an
international scale.
My advice for other developers
out there is use the tools,
keep refining your
product, keep innovating,
and make your application a
success, just like PicMix.